salut à tous cette vidéo est sponsorisée
par mobile Legend Adventure mobile
Legend Adventure c'est un idle RPG
apprécié au 27 millions de
téléchargements collectter des
ressources et devenez plus fort
simplement en dormant les ressources
s'accumulent automatiquement 24 heur sur
24 et 7 jours sur 7 les héros se battent
seul pendant que vous faites autre
chosees waouh mais ça veut dire que je
peux faire plein d'autres choses en même
temps mais vous pouvez jouer aussi ah ok
on va faire ça alors mobile Legend
adventure le jeu idéal pour occuper
votre temps libre et jouer 5 ou 10
minutes quand vous avez une pause avec
son scénario captivant et ses 85 héros
uniques 85 mais ça fait au moins des
centaines pardon faites preuve de
stratégie pour composer votre équipe et
profitez du spectacle avec des
personnages de haute qualité waouh j'ai
gâteau
caca c'est un vrai personnage dès
maintenant et jusqu'au 6 janvier
participer à l'événement de Noël et
recevez des récompenses uniques faites
des vœux et attendez les cadeaux du Père
Noël et par Père Noël je veux évidemment
dire Jean-François du service marketing
bonjour connectez-vous tous les jours
pour recevoir 70 parchemin d'in
voocation gratuit et collecter des skins
de Noël à durée limitée jeux gratuit
disponible sur Android et iOS
téléchargez-le avec le lien en
description utilisez le code à l'écran
pour obtenir 1000 diamants et 20
parchemin de voocation
[Musique]
1 2 3 4
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il était une fois l'histoire de deux
gentils hommes le premier s'appelait
John carmac un programmeur de génie ses
talents de codage impressionnit la
galerie j'ai programmé commander Kin sur
MS2 qu' mon patron ne regardait pas si
les jeux sont fluides sur PC c'est
vraiment grâce à moi
efftivement n'avait pas son cerveau
aiguisé aujourd'hui encore nos jeux
serai
éclatés le éta John Romo son truc à lui
cétait de faire des niveau
les Rost avec je vais gagner des
milliards em il fond une nouvelle
société et dans le je
vidéo tout WOL
[Musique]
c'est vraiment un livre pour enfants ça
Roméo et karmac rien n'arrêtait leur
ascension et très rapidement ils se
noyaient dans leur propre pognon mais si
les deux hommes étaient déjà rentrés
dans les anals KAC serait la fourmie et
Roméo l'amigale la cale ta gueule l'
était concentré sérieux on ne plaisante
pas quand l'autre aimait parler fr les
lumières des camé pendant le
développement de Quake les problèmes
commençèent Romero était frustré énervé
et ses collègues l'engueulaire tu te
déconcentres tes équipes tournent en
rond fini le de jeu au lieu de
faire le con mais j'en ai marre moi je
veux m'amuser sortir le jeu vite c'est
tout ce à quoi vous pensez Roméo en tant
que créatif vous laisse lâcher renouvelz
le genre créer la nouveauté mais carac
lui ne l'entendait pas ainsi et de plein
d'idées cool
raccourci les deux hommes avaient du jeu
vidéo une vision bien différente et les
altercations devenaient de plus en plus
fréquentes le premier pensait que la
technique était la seule chose qui
comptait tout le monde s'en fout de
l'histoire ce qui compte c'est de
s'amuser le second ne voyait pas les
choses comme ainsi et sans hésiter il
répondit sans idées neuvees moi
j'abandonne nos jeux n'intéresseront
personne alors ce qui devait arriver
arriva et Romero sa propre société fonda
en grande pompe le premier jeu il
annonça et celui-ci s'appellera da
katana en japonais ça veut dire gros CP
da katana c'est un jeu de légende parmi
les jeux pourris c'est un peu comme Duke
Nukem Forever mais sans les nichons et
comme pour nuk Nukem il est important de
comprendre comment ce jeu est apparu
quand Romero quitte sa société il décide
de faire l'inverse de tout ce que
faisait h software il développe dans des
petits studios boum il investit dans des
bureaux énormes il bossait sur un seul
jeu à la fois boou il décide de bosser
sur trois jeux en parallèle ils ont fait
des jeux à succès Booum il fait une
grosse merde ah non pardon j'ai les
apppp à la fin de l'histoire revenons en
arrière Romero investit le tiers de sa
fortune personnelle il va démarcher des
éditeurs comme idos qui investissent
également une partie de la montagne de
pogon générée par Tomb Raider h jeux
sont préachetés et sa compagnie
s'appellera ion
stor le jeu s'ouvre par une cinématique
qui dure tellement longtemps que j'ai eu
la sensation de voyager dans le temps
heureusement que cette version PC est
redoublée contrairement à la version
Nintendo 64 qui est
ah sort éfique en plus de ramer assez
pour participer aux épreuves d'aviron
l'histoire donc se passe dans un Japon
futuriste on y incarne ho Miyamoto
évidemment en référence à Shigeru
Miyamoto le mec qui a créé l'excellent
Wii Music qui est un épéiste modeste qui
s'entraîne dans son dojo camp par une
belle nuit d'été ben je vais en Bretagne
un vieillard arrive et nous raconte
l'histoire de ses ancêtres la famille
ebiara je vous promets que vous ne
regretterez pas le temps que vous
m'aurez
accordé ça c'est ce que toute personne
normale aurait fait mais là on est dans
un jeu vidéo loin dans le passé il y a
des millénaires les familles ebiara et
Mishima étent opposé dans la lutte pour
le pouvoir au Japon jusqu'au moment o
Usagi miamoto ancêtre d'IRO forgea
l'arme suprême la
grosp qui permit à la famille ebiara de
vaincre la famille Mishima grâce à ses
pouvoirs mystiques qui permettent à son
propriétaire de voyager dans l'espace et
le temps des katanas des samourails du
futur qui voyagent dans le temps
attendez je note quelque chose dans
cette lettre je la cè et on se retrouve
à la fin de la vidéo les Mishima furent
donc vaincus par les ebiara mettant un
terme à la guerre des siècles plus tard
un descendant de ebiara se mit en tête
de retrouver le Daikatana qui avait
disparu depuis la grande bataille
j'espère que vous suivez jeté dans les
entrailles du mon Fuji par votre ancêtre
car trop puissant et trop dangereux et
biara retrouve donc la trace de l'épée
mais Pelot
twist excellente blague son assistant se
révèle être en fait Kage Mishima
descendant de la famille Mishima et la
précédé il dérobe le Daikatana et
emploie ses pouvoirs magique pour
voyager dans le temps et changer le
cours de
l'histoire mon Dieu ils ont changé le
cours du temps tout le monde porte des
masques de dinosaures le vieil homme
nous demande donc de retrouver le
Daikatana détenu par Mishima ainsi que
sa propre fille mikiko disparu pour
avoir tenté de s'emparer de l'épéerouver
ma fille
etatana et j'aime beaucoup comment notre
héros gob instantanément tout ce qui est
dit je suis un prince nigérien venu du
futur je suis venu ton aide pour
pouironstituer la corn magiquein d'Align
pas plus j'attrape mon manteau attendez
une minute qu'est-ce qu' me dit que vous
êtes vraiment nigérien
et ainsi commença la création du jeu et
le moins qu'on puisse dire c'est que
c'était ambitieux 15 niveaux 25 armes 64
monstres 4 périodes temporelles et en
plus le jeu doit être une révolution
visuelle mois pour tout finir sachant
que l'équipe part de zé qu'il faut
recruter tout le
personnelz évidemment grâce au fr fil
Paros at un peu n'importe qui oua j'ai
très hâte de rencontrer notre nouvelle
équipe de
[Musique]
développement pour ma part j'ai mon
petit succès avec desam Surb rider avec
la r
poil encore la
[Musique]
poil
moi votre fille la photo
je peux la prendre la
photoah il a qui ce chien c'est c'est le
mien en fait je me suis dit peut-être
c'était possible
de en gros Romero commence à recruter
des gens qui ont construit des maps sur
le moteur de Quake avec comme seul
critère de recrutement leur nombre de
téléchargement sur internet donc ben
forcément ça donne un peu n'importe quoi
le jeu commence donc son développement
sur le moteur de Quake 1 est censé
sortir fin 97 mais à le 3 de cette même
année h software présente la démo de 2
littéralement sur le stand d'à côté qui
évidemment ridiculise Daikatana Romero
décide donc de repousser la sortie du
jeu pour le remettre à la pointe de la
technologie il se dit bêtement
tranquille nos programmeurs connaissent
déjà le moteur de quun ça leur prendra
quoi de TR mois pour faire le
portage merde le jeu sort donc sur PC
avec un portage sur Nintendo 64 et sur
Game Boy Color vraiment ah
oui ok après très longue cinématique le
vieux meurt assassiné en nous disant de
se planquer dans son cercueil quand ils
viendront chercher son corps
débouyz-vous pour vous faire enfermer
dans le cercueil alors si j'étais
mesquin je dirais ok mais la personne
qui emmène le cercueil avant de le
refermer elle va peut-être bien voir
qu'il y a deux corps dedans non oups
mais passons commençons le jeu
ok ok ok je je je sais même pas pas
recommencer ne t'inquiète pas vas-y
doucement et dis-moi où c'est que le jeu
t'a touché bon alors déjà le jeu ser en
mai 2000 sur le moteur de Quake 2 et
soyons clair ça en
2000 en 2000 déjà il y a K 3 qui sort
mais ça fait surtout 3 ans que Golden
Eye est sorti 2 ans que Half Life est
sorti c'est comme ce pointter en 3è
année de fac d'art appliqué et de
ramener le dessin de ta petite sœur mais
je sais pas j'ai du mal à dire ce qui
m'agresse le plus en ce début de partie
est-ce que c'est l'image verpice le fait
que le jeu te fasse commencer sans
préliminaire par un niveau dans les
égouts un peu comme si tu allais dans un
bar et que tu commençais à vomir avant
même de boire ton premier verre ou
est-ce que c'est le sound design
instantanément
[Musique]
insupportable c'est le sonide le pire
c'est que il y a une musique dans le jeu
qui est pas immonde quand on l'écoute
mais pour une raison inexplicable ils
l'ont baissé au minimum du coup les ves
moments où tu l'entends on dirait juste
qu'il y a une fête à côté ah mais c'est
vos gueules je je m'entends plus
m'emmerder là par contre on a mis les
brutages à fond c'est important pour
l'ambiance
mais venons-en à un des principaux
problèmes de ce DA
katana les armes j'ai commencé à
soupçonner que quelque chose allait mal
se passer quand après moins de 30
secondes j'ai voulu tirer avec la
première arme du jeu sous l'eau et que
ça m'a pété à la gueule sans raison et
là je me suis dit mais mais non c'est
pas possible c'est moi qui fait quelque
chose de mal je veux dire la première
arme du jeu ne peut pas être autant à
chier c'est comme si ton date se mettait
à lâcher des énormes caisses au bout de
quelques minutes lors de votre premier
rendez-vous au restaurant mais si le
problème c'est que toutes les armes
d'une manière ou d'une autre te
reviennne à la gueule hein l'arme de
base lance des projectiles qui
rebondissent sur les murs et notamment
dans ta gueule ce qui n'est pas très
pratique quand tous les ennemis pendant
les deux premières heures de jeu font 10
cm de haut et que donc tu dois viser tes
pieds mais ne vous inquiétez pas une
autre arme arrive peu de temps après je
vous déteste le lanceur de mines j'ai
jamais vu un truc qui inflige autant de
dégâts à soi-même à part poster son
opinion politique sur Twitter he cette
arme lance des mines 2 m devant toi qui
ont un rayon d'explosion de 4 m à quoi
sert cette merde même si tu veux jouer
un temps soit peu intelligent en te
décalant dans un coin de mur pour tirer
tu passes ton temps à coller tes mines
sur des murs invisibles parce que les
hitbox de ce jeu sont tout éclatés
coucou merde ah mais allez mais vas-y
mais qu'est-ce qu'il me tue là
celui je vis la conte de ta race ta mère
ta sœur ton cul mais calme-toi j'ai pas
besoin de me calmer j'ai besoin que lui
il arrête de m'énerver parce que en gros
tu as le choix entre le lance mine et
ses murs invisiblebles le lance roquette
qui tire des mini bombes nucléaire le
lanceur de boule disco qui tue tout le
monde dans la pièce toi y compris les
armes de ce jeu sont tellement à chier
que le wiki a littéralement une
catégorie intitulée self damage vous
savez quoi je vais juste utiliser mes
point parce que là au moins je risque
rien et le DA katana vous me direz
l'arme ultime la grosse épée qu'on doit
retrouver le nom du jeu littéralement
mais la vraie question c'est plutôt
pourquoi est-ce que j'utiliseraai un
sabre dans un monde où j'ai des
de canon laser c'est cette scène dans
Indiana Jones là mais en
pire dès 97 la campagne de promotion du
jeu commence et pour ça rien de tel
qu'un petit peu de violence Romero va
faire de vous sa
ouais niveau bon goût c'était pas
vraiment au top il aurait peut-être
mieux fait de s'occuper de son équipe
qui pendant ce temps-là allait tout
droit au casspipe oui effectivement
pendant que da katana a commencait sa
campagne de promotion de l'autre côté tu
avais les programmeurs et les artistes
qui s'engueulaient et des systèmes de
jeux entiers qui étaient implantés et
servis à moitié non mais tiens regardez
voilà wouh j'ai level up génial et oui
parce que en plus d'être un mauvais FPS
da katana c'est aussi un mauvais
RPG super le jeu possède C statistiques
power Atta speed accro pour la CRR
branche je suppose et vitalité mais un
truc qui aurait été bien c'est par
exemple d'expliquer à quoi ça sert genre
c'est quoi la différence entre Power et
attaque ça ça sert à quoi la vitalité vu
que de toute façon mon nombre de PV est
limité à 200 c'est quoi
l'ACRO l'ro même pas vous êtes même pas
foutu de prendre une police lisible là
le seul truc que j'ai remarqué he c'est
qu'au bout de plusieurs heur de jeu
visiblement power avait l'air
d'augmenter mes dégâts voilà donc je
deviens plus puissant donc mes armes
deviennent plus puissantes
logique fatigué que vos balles ne
traversent pas les murs oui prenez des
vitamines mais c'est n'importe quoi dis
donc après le hors d'œuvre des égouts on
arrive donc dans la prison et il va être
l'heure de commencer à cliquer un pe
partout au hasard sur les différentes
consoles pour chercher les interrupteurs
cachés et on aura la joie d'entendre à
chaque fois votre personnage faire
ça c'est bon on a compris la blague pié
ou ah oui nous y voilà le grumeau dans
le lait le premier compagnon le
visuellement improbable Superfly
référence au film Superfly en effet
Romero dans ce jeu avait à l'esprit de
s'inspirer grandement d'un body movie
mais trop complexe manque de moyens et
de temps les compagnons étaient de la
merde tout simplement et si vous pensiez
déjà avoir tout vu baissez votre
ceinture et ouvrez grand votre cul
Superfly est l'ancien chef de la
sécurité de la prison où on se trouve et
bien sûr on peut compter sur son aide
précieuse pour nous aider à retrouver
Mik suis cher d'une jeune femme elle a
dû arriver il y a quelques semaines h
une asiatique oui c'est elle tu veux
dire que tu as vu une fille asiatique au
Japon oui c'est sûrement
elle mais déjà avant d'aller plus loin
excuse-moi candis je réalise maintenant
que tu étais loin d'être la
per les compagnons d'andai katana cétait
un des gros point de communication du
jeu les compagnons étaient d'ailleurs
une chose unique à cette version PC
puisque la version Nintendo 64 ne les
avait pas intégré tu passais ton temps à
te battre tout seul et à buter des
centaines d'ennemis et dès qu'une
cinématique
arrivait ho je pense que nous mais
mais vous êtes qui merde je
ramasse donc Superfly et je monte d'un
étage quand ce dernier se dit qu'il aait
bien attaquer les robots géants amenu
évidemment il meurt et quand votre
compagnon meurt dans ce jeu et bien
c'est le game over oh je n'aime pas
cette direction du coup je vais plutôt
regarder de l'autre côté en fait
d'ailleurs alors j'ai pas précisé mais
je joue a une version patchée du jeu qui
me permet de cocher cette petite case
qui permet de sauvegarder n'importe où
parce que sans cette petite case et bien
j'aurais dû récupérer des cristaux de
sauvegarde qui limiteraiit le nombre de
fois où j'aurais pu sauvegarder un petit
peu à la manière du premier Tomb Raider
et je vais être transparent avec
vous
ah je m'adore bref heureusement
que le jeu a été patché pour les
sauve-gardes parce qu'un truc qu'il aime
bien faire c'est genre te piéger dans
des endroits où tu n'as aucun autre
choix à part bien aller te faire mettre
en attendant la mort ou aussi plusieurs
moments où ils ont placé un loading donc
une sauvegarde juste avant un mob
connard connard connard connard ou
encore mieux des sauvegarde automatique
où le jeu décide subitement que ça
serait une bonne idée de faire
apparaître 15 ennemis qui n'étaient pas
là avant le chargement vous êtes sérieux
là c'est quoi ce de peloton
d'exécution
subitement
mer maisah oui super allez merci au
chargement fait ça bravo
j'applaudis et en plus je commence bien
de dos et il y a l'autre connard au
milieu et
mais mais pourquoi est-ce
que je dois vivre ça et pourquoi mon
personnage il nage dans la sauce tomate
j'y vois rien merde ok maintenant faites
preuve d'imagination pendant à peu près
une minute vos armes vous tuent il y a
des pièges et vous faites un game over à
chaque fois que l'un de vos compagnons
qui ont à peu près l'intelligence d'une
chaise pliante meurt le tout sans
sauvegarde j'en suis à un stade où je
pense que certains jeux ont été créés
uniquement pour tester ma patience en
fait et tu as oublié les dégâts de chut
et j'ai oublié les dégâts de chut katana
est-ce qui s'appelle fast FPS ce qui
veut dire que votre personnage passe de
zéro à 100 km/h en moins de 1 seconde
regardez à quel point je vais vite là
sans même avoir augmenté mes points en
vitesse à quel moment quelqu'un s'est
dit que dans un jeu comme ça avec une
vitesse pareille et un design si
vertical ça serait une bonne idée
d'ajouter des dégâts de chute ah
sérieusement je met même dans l'eau on
prend des dégâts bah ça il avait raison
Romero le jeu il marche tellement sur la
gueule queouis pour le coup j'ai
vraiment l'impression d'être sa
c'est combien 20 balles quoi bref donc
je recharge sur que si je décide de
partir loin devant mon compagnon
histoire de buter les ennemis loin
devant lui pour que lui ne se fasse pas
tuer
[Musique]
ok trè essai
[Applaudissements]
oui votre compagnon est visiblement très
émotionnellement investi he pour un mec
qui vous a rencontré il y a moins de 5
minutes donc je recharge la sauvegarde
je réussis à avancer un peu je tue les
ennemis
et il est il est mort dans la porte il
est mort dans la de porte je
je c'est ça qu'il aurait fallu mettre
sur la pub du métro là avec le lapin qui
se coince les doigts dans la porte ça ça
aurait vachement plus impressionné les
enfants non pas le lapin et oui je dis
vos compagnons parce qu'au bout de
quelques heures de jeu ce n'est pas un
compagnon mais deux qui vous
[Musique]
suivront pour deux fois plus de fun e
mikiko ça te dirait de venir avec moi et
de te coincer dans les murs comme une
conne avec l're débile
[Musique]
mental cool bienvenue donc à mikiko un
fille du vieux type du début une
sympathique demoiselle Swan
[Musique]
ok calme-toi Mussolini quelque chose me
dit cependant que ce personnage qui
cherche le Daikatana absolument qui tue
les gens des armées et qui propose de
laisser tomber mes alliés à la moindre
occasion nouvelle de Superfly pas la
moindre idée pourrait être n'importe où
autant l'oublier et nous échapper au
plus vite de cette horrible ah peut-être
quelque chose de louche lisons le livret
du jeu sa mère est morte quand elle
était jeune cela dit il est impossible
de savoir à quel point ce meurtre l'a
affecté trois petits
points c'est sûrement mon imagination
bref vos compagnons ne sont pas que de
simples PN qui vous suivent ils
possèdent tous les deux leur bar
d'armure mais aussi leurs armes et leurs
munitions donc il faudra aussi
régulièrement les laisser prendre vos
items vos armes ou vos mipacks enfin ça
c'est quand ils veulent bien parce que
dans la plupart des cas ils seront pris
de spasme de panique quand vous leur
demanderez de ramasser un objet et
encore ça c'est quand ils acceptent
prends l'armure certainement pas non
attends je t'ai pas demandé si tu étais
d'accord prends l'armure tel n'est pas
ma volonté c'est pas vrai mais je rêve
prends prends le soin bordel je n'en ai
pas l'intention tu as deux points de vie
prends le soin
j'en veux pas j'aime pas la
couleur ça pique la
langue évidemment le jeu ne te laisse
pas finir le niveau sans tes compagnons
donc à partir de ce moment-là les choses
prennent rapidement la tournure d'une
gigantesque quête d'escorte où tu dois
accompagner deux bébés suicidaires
non bon alors après vous pouvez quand
même donner quelques commande basique he
du style suis-moi reste ici ramasse cet
item je jure que je vais te mettre Doig
dans le cul si tu continues à te coincer
partout mais c'est pareil là je dis à
mon compagnon de rester là je pars seul
devant lui pour nettoyer et il s'est
fait tuer par des mouches l'ennemi le
plus de basique du jeu quand je
dis reste là ça veut pas dire ne te
défends pas par pitié évidemment ça
serait trop simple je peux pas juste
appuyer sur un bouton d'ordre du genre
suis-moi en étant un petit peu plus loin
devant eux pour qu'ils me rejoignent non
non surtout ou pas à chaque fois que je
veux leur donner un ordre je suis obligé
de faire tout le niveau en arrière
jusqu'à eux pour leur sessurer à
l'oreille
suis-moi bref on va pas rester mil an
là-dessus finissons avec un bestof
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
inspiré d'un Bud movie ce truc c'est
quoi le Budy movie cet hiver ne ratez
pas le bu movie qui va faire sensation
je vaiser dans le couvremi et ce coup fa
pas John et la chaise pliante vous allez
en de de
rire après avoir donc récupéré le
Daikatana on rencontre Mishima qui a
voyager dans le temps parce que la
souure du temps bref on s'en fout il
possède lui aussi le Daikatana et nous
dit crois ou même sffleuré le monde tel
que nous le connaissons cesserait
d'exister et nous serions tous anéantis
après quoi il décide de nous tuer en
nous envoyant voyager dans le temps non
pitié non ne fais pas ça ça marchera pas
c'est très bien ça marche jamais dans
les scénario ce genre de merde mais fa à
ce cauchemar par pitié qu'on en finisse
non et nous voilà donc arrivés en Grèce
sans nos
compagnons évidemment on retrouve bien
vite castor et Polux avant de se faire
un nouveau téléporter ce coupci au
Moyen-Âge l'occasion pour mikiko de
briller par ses talents de déduction ce
ne serait pas un village là-bas
oui
mikiko on y aura bien sûr notre de
nouvelles armes comme l'arme qui tire
des boules empoisonnées qui rebondissent
partout repose ça tout de suite ou
d'autres armes dont le but m'échappe
complètement comme le marteau d'ADES qui
visiblement ne sert à rien par
s'infliger des dégâts à soi-même oh mon
dieu toute façon ça veut dire quoi le
marteau d'ADES ça existe même pas et
pourquoi pas la corn mususe de Jésus
aussi bref faites comme si ce niveaux
n'existaient pas et on arrive donc à Los
Angeles en 2030 pour le niveau final et
ce niveau c'est un peu le boss des tests
de patience pour voir si vous méritez la
fin du jeu regardez-mo ça qu'est-ce que
c'est que ce bordel on est où là dans ce
quid game bon allez courage on est
presque arrivé au bout du tunnel le pire
est derrière
nous j'ai l'attention de hamster que tu
es frais à coup de fusil à pompe mais
c'est bon on est au boss final
ok c'est tu es bizarre et après un
affrontement contre Mishima horriblement
dur où il faut faire super attention à
ce que les Sabres ne se touchent pas
parce que sinon absolument rien ne se
passe mikiko plante Superfly dans le dos
et vous trahit pour s'emparer du
Daikatana oh mon dieu quel incroyable
retournement c'est donc l'heure du
véritable boss fin c'est déjà fini je
vais même pas commenter ça je veux juste
dire que je suis heureux que ça soit
terminé pour le reste on se reverra au
procès ho rétablit la ligne temporelle
je sais pas trop comment et enferme le
sabre sous sa maison comme dans le Davin
chicode Kimiko est en vie avec Superfly
dans une autre ligne temporelle et
attendez je rouvre la lettre du
début tellement après 3 ans de douleur
et mout problème le rush final pour
sortir le jeu commence avec pour
objectif Noël 99 mais c'est encore un
échec hein le délai est dépassé et les
quelques semaines que s'était accordé
l'équipe pour peaufiner les détails se
transfore rapidement en un crunch de
plusieurs mois et dans le temps et la
douleur le jeu fut accouché après la
démission de plusieurs directeurs et
d'un tas d'employés une année entière de
labeur 14 he par jour à cravacher sous
la chaleur des ordinateurs pour faire
d'un bol de merde un Stak haché détail
amusant dans une des filiale de la
société sans Romero sur le dos les gens
faisaient de la qualité à l'image de cet
autre jeu créé par un studio annexe qui
reçut des avis élogieux et dont le nom
est Deo au sexe et maintenant que
l'histoire est finie quelle est donc la
morale mes braves amis à vouloir voler
trop haut Romero s'est brûlé les ailes
il s'imaginait être le héros mais il
oublia
l'essentiel lorsque l'envie vous prend
d'essayer quelque chose de bien abandonn
rapidement avant d'échouer comme un
chieny
Noël
[Musique]